[Music]
my name is Nick Mason my musician of
played drums for Pink Floyd the last 50
years and I'm also a fanatical racing
enthusiast I think we could say I've
been coming to Goodwood since the first
hill time 20 rather how long ago it was
and I'm still enjoying it today it's
completely different now the first time
there were no demonstrations at all it
was a straight Hill time everyone was
timed in different classes and it was
wonderful and it's now still wonderful
but completely different it's sort of
become the new motor shop
I never wanted to be a car collector I
wanted to go motor racing so what
happened was that thanks to the success
of the records I ended up being able to
keep everything I've erased and I bought
the Ferrari 250 GTO about 40 40
something years ago everyone thought I
was completely insane including myself I
think but now that they think I'm the
sort of Warren Buffett of motoring
I've had the car so long now it is part
of the family I'm really familiar with
it so I absolutely recognized the view
out of it but I still think it's one of
the greatest views that you can possibly
have rather than great geographical
landscapes that beautiful bonnet
stretching ahead is a wonderful thing i
remembers of when I was quite young
seeing one of these cars are good with
peering into it and thinking or be great
to be in there and doing that it's a
driver's car is fantastic but it's also
then got a sprinkle of real history and
it's part of the Ferrari history part of
Lamoure that for me has always been the
great
[Music]
you